here for reaction former national
security adviser for president trump
robert o'brien ambassador thank you so
much for joining us tonight um
there's a lot going on in the world
stage
but this idea that we can do something
tough to russia
um look joe biden can't even protect our
southern border what makes him what
makes the world think that he's gonna
protect taiwan and protect ukraine i
mean he can't even protect texas
well it's great to be with you jason
early merry christmas and happy new year
to you and the viewers
look
we know what works in international
affairs it was the ronald reagan
doctrine of peace through strength and
that was the doctrine that president
trump employed and when we look weak
when america looks sweet to our our
adversaries whether it's
china attempting to re uh build its
empire russia trying to recapture the
soviet empire iran uh trying to re
institute the old persian empire
when they look at us and and we look
weak that's provocative and so we we
need to make sure that we we we in that
that appearance and it's not just the
the the foreign policy
white papers it's the fact that
inflation is running rampant it's the
fact that when president trump left
office oil was roughly 30 a barrel and
it's on its way to a hundred dollars a
barrel and we were energy independent
it's the fact that we cancelled the
keystone pipeline as you mentioned it's
the fact that the southern border is
totally out of control it's the debacle
that occurred with the evacuation of of
afghanistan so our adversaries look at
all those things uh beyond what's just
in the foreign policy white papers which
which may not be terrible
and then they they smell weakness and
that's provocative and that that that's
the sort of thing that could end us end
up you know pulling us into some sort of
conflict and we have to be
extraordinarily careful
you know usually an administration will
have a knee-jerk reaction to something
happening on the international stage by
saying oh there's going to be sanctions
but i mean how many hundreds of times
can we say sanctioned sanctioned
sanctions against russia i mean do they
really have any effect at this point i
mean is it really a deterrent is putin
sit back and say oh my goodness another
sanction look out you know what am i
gonna do
well it's a great question uh you know
vladimir putin said that the loss of the
soviet empire was the greatest
geopolitical catastrophe of the the
century and so he'd like to knit belarus
and ukraine and the baltics back into
his russian empire and uh and we've got
to stop it and when you look at
sanctions i'll tell you one sanction
that worked and it was the nordstrom 2
pipeline sanctions in the trump
administration we stopped nordstrom 2 in
its tracks it couldn't be completed they
couldn't get get it through the denmark
denmark's waters and
eez
they couldn't complete the pipeline and
unfortunately we gave them uh since
president biden took office we gave them
the nordstrom pipeline uh and got
nothing in return we didn't get security
guarantees for ukraine we didn't get
anything else in return so so the
sanctions that could be effective uh we
haven't taken so i i don't think putin's
concerned about ineffective sanctions uh
listing an oligarch
under ofac or something of that nature
but he he was concerned about nordstrom
too
and there are other things other yeah
you know steps that we can take if he
did move on ukraine like cutting rush
off from the international banking
system
yeah why biden early in his presidency
gave the nordstream pipeline back to
russia for absolutely nothing as you
pointed out is one of the great
mysteries guys never negotiated anything
and that's what you that's what you get
and now we're in a tough spot we don't
have that
as a card to play so ambassador brian uh
merry christmas thank you so much for
joining us tonight on hannity we do
appreciate it